[Music]
and now here's something neat that i
wanted you all to see take a look
hi drew my name is fernanda and in
celebration of hispanic heritage month
i'm going to talk to you about the
history behind the iconic katrinas that
are often associated with dia de los
muertos in mexico the first ever katrina
was actually a political cartoon by jose
guadalupe posada and it was published in
1913 during mexican revolutionary times
the original katrina was drawn wearing a
big hat heavy earrings and a gown that
was fashionable for women of the
aristocracy of the time since it was
mexican revolutionary times it was meant
to be commentary on the hypocrisy of the
rich that no matter how big your hat is
how fashionable your clothes are or how
much money you have in the end we are
all just skeletons and this type of
katrina is still recreated by artisans
across mexico and you can really buy
these anywhere fast forward a couple
decades the catherine reemerged in pop
culture after a legendary artist diego
rivera recreated it for one of his most
iconic murals that is mural dream of a
sunday afternoon in alameda park in the
historic center of mexico city he is
painted as a child holding hands with
the katrina and behind him is painted
his famous wife frivolo and over time
these katrinas began to be combined with
the other los muertos a day where we
celebrate life death and life after
death and i personally believe that
these modern day recreations of the
katrina still uphold the same message
that jose guadalupe posada was trying to
tell it's a way of unifying humanity
during dia de los muertos showing that
in the end we are all just skeletons i
hope you enjoyed the little history
lesson drew and i hope to also see you
rocking a catrina for the other los
muertos this year
i hope that you enjoyed that as much as
i did
[Music]